Друзі, всім привіт! Живучи в Німеччині,
я постійно відкриваю для себе
місцеві традиції. Нині всі
готуються до Різдва. І щоб відчути
дух цього свята, треба
завітати на Вайнахтсмаркт.
Так німецькою називають
різдвяний ярмарок. Пропоную вам
разом зі мною подивитися чим частують,
що наливають, що продають
і як розважають відвідувачів
різдвяного ярмарку у Німеччині.
Також пропоную
використати різдвяний ярмарок
як машину часу, щоб опинитися
в середньовічній Німеччині.
Це Вайнахтсмаркт у самому серці Бонна.
Клімат тут у порівнянні з Україною м'який.
На вулиці -  плюс чотири. Снігу немає,
тож різдвяну атмосферу
створює ілюмінація і декорації ярмарку,
який відкривається
вже об 11-й ранку. У цій крамниці
продають  німецькі різдвяні сувеніри.
Поруч висять
Санкт-Ніколаус, в українській традиції –
Святий Миколай, і Вайнахтсман -
Дід Мороз. Знайти український
відповідник натомість неможливо
для оцих фігурок на поличках.
Це Ройхерман, у перекладі - курець.
Ці фігурки з Саксонії
пахкають люльками з ладаном 18 століття.
Ціни на них захмарні:
ось цей, наприклад, коштує 68 євро.
Не дивно, адже це ручна робота.
Ось з цієї частини здіймається дим.
Ручкою можна писати,
сюди закріпляти нотатки,
а ще вішати на нього
щось на магнітиках.
Ще один улюбленець різдвяних продажів –
Лускунчик. Казка Гофманна
і балет Чайковського зробили його
одним із найвпізнаваніших зимових
персонажів.
Ялинку в Німеччині прикрашають з 14-го століття.
Одна з найтрадиційніших ялинкових прикрас –
солом'яна.
Янголятко ручної роботи коштує 9 євро.
Ще один
обов'язковий атрибут – Різдвяна зірка.
Вона символізує віфлеємську зірку,
яка вказувала трьом царям
шлях до новонародженого Ісуса.
На боннському ярмарку їм
присвячена ціла ятка.
Окрім класичної п'ятикутної зірки, у Німеччині популярна
різдвяна гернгутська зірка.
Вона має 25 променів.
Походить з міста Гернгут
у Саксонії.
Найпопулярніший продукт на німецькому Різдвяному ярмарку –
це гаряче вино зі спеціями,
яке в Україні називають глінтвейн.
Тут такого слова не знають
і називають гаряче вино глювайн,
німецькою – вино, що палає.
У Бонні його наливають
між цими двома оленями, що співають.
Що ж, піду спробую.
Прошу!
За рецептом там є кориця, гвоздика, цукор,
все що треба.
Вміст алкоголю приблизно 8,9 відсотка.
А до  якої температури розігріваєте?
До 70 градусів, щоб не випарувався алкоголь.
Кружка глінтвейну коштує 5 євро.
Із заставою.
Якщо повернути чашку, отримаєте назад 2,5 євро.
За бажання її можна лишити собі як сувенір.
Від співу оленів над яткою з глювайном,
схоже, і завжди суворий
Бетховен трохи подобрішав.
Різдвяні пісні співають  і безтурботні
німецькі пенсіонерки.
Я прижджаю сюди зі своїми односельчанками
автобусом. Ми тут регулярно зустрічаємося.
Їмо, п’ємо
і витрачаємо купу грошей. (сміх)
Я вже втретє цьогоріч
на різдвяному ярмарку. Вже була у Фулді,
Вісбадені і зараз..
де ми?
А в Бонні! (сміються)
Закусити  глювайн  можна традиційними величезними
медовими пряниками з побажаннями
або різдвяним смаженим мигдалем.
Вартість ста грамів –
4 євро 50 центів.
Моя родина займається цим вже четверте покоління.
Це великий мигдальний
дім у Бонні. Тут ви маєте
на вибір понад 30 різновидів
смаженого мигдалю.
Увечері на Вайнахтсмаркті у Бонні стає
набагато більше людей. Всі поспішають
сюди після роботи, щоб випити глювайну
і поспілкуватися з друзями.
Увечері стає очевидним,
що різдвяний ярмарок – це ще й унікальне
соціальне явище.
Весь ярмарок перетворюється на величезний
дискусійний клуб. Ідеальний спосіб
коротати довгі зимові вечори!
А у містечку Зіґбург біля Бонна  традиційно проходить
середньовічний різдвяний ярмарок.
Здається, ніби перенісся
сюди на машині часу.
Так звучить шалмей –
це пращур гобоя. А мелодія,
яку я виконував, - англійська
танцювальна мелодія з 12 століття.
Всі продавці вбрані у стародавній одяг. А ще тут можна
придбати речі, які давно
не випускають на фабриках.
Ми продаємо тут, на ярмарку, скляні пера,
виготовлені у приватній майстерні.
Скляні пера винайшли в 11-му  столітті,
причому не в Європі, а в Персії .
У Європі вони з'явилися
лише у 17-му столітті.
Перо має наконечник
у формі цибулини з багатьма канавками.
Один раз опустивши перо у чорнила,
можна провести лінію завдовжки
два метри. До пера
можна придбати записники зі шкіряною
обкладинкою у стилі
середньовічних книжок. Поруч
на дровах печуть хліб.
Мій колега саме випікає булочки з родзинками.
На рожнІ смажать цілих кабанів. Єдине,
що відрізняє цей процес від середньовіччя, -
електроприлад,
що крутить туші. А за тисячолітнім
скандинавським рецептом з використанням
диму, вогню і солі готують
філе лосося.
А справжня таємнича атмосфера
на різдвяному ярмарку в Зіґбурзі
починається ввечері,
коли всі запалюють свічки.
А  що ж за середньовіччя без ворожіння?
У мене в родині усі ворожили. У нас це належить до традиції,
до виховання. Моя родина -
синті. Ми не вчилися
передбачати майбутнє по книжках,
у нас це в крові.
За словами ворожки, вона має офіційний дозвіл на свою діяльність.
Анжеліна передбачає долю
на картах таро та за лініями на долоні.
Звичайно ж, не обійтись у середньовіччі
і без коваля.
Поруч у величезних чанах варять гороховий суп.
Смажені каштани – ще одна проста
і поживна їжа.
Їстівні каштани походять
з Італії. Ми продаємо їх тут
вже багато років. І коли холодно,
німці дуже люблять ласувати
теплими каштанами на різдвяному  ринку.
Як і тисячі років тому, люди гріються біля вогню
або ласують найстарішим
алкогольним напоєм в історії людства,
зробленим з меду.
Весела продавчиня мету пояснює
переваги цього напою.
Головна відмінність між метом та глінтвейном у тому,
що мет роблять з натурального меду.
Це стародавній напій, один з перших
алкогольних напоїв, який робить
людей веселими і добряче зігріває.
А на сцені середньовічного театру -
жонглери вогнем.
Сабіна, яку жонглер обрав серед глядачів,
за його командою має вийти
з вогняної пастки.
Бажаю і вам, наші шановні глядачі,
щоб у 2018 році
все вам вдавалося!
До зустрічі на DW
у Новому році!